as we head into December we're going to
start hearing more about the war on
Christmas but before the focus shifts in
that direction it's worth noticing the
much more direct and intense War being
waged on the holiday that we just
celebrated which is uh Thanksgiving the
war on Thanksgiving has been raging for
years now as the cultural powers that be
attempt to turn a time of gratitude and
celebration into an occasion for guilt
and recrimination now we know that these
forces seek to destroy all Traditions
passed To Us by our ancestors and this
is the primary issue that they have with
Christmas too uh with every holiday that
they themselves didn't invent is that
it's a tradition passed To Us by our
ancestors and so they hate it
reflexively but Thanksgiving like
Columbus Day is especially egregious in
their eyes because it Harkens back to
the European conquest of North America
which is an historical event that these
days is supposed to provoke nothing but
grief and lamentation in fact for years
the left has tried to to literally
Rebrand Thanksgiving as on Thanksgiving
or
as it's called in some quarters now
Thanksgiving is a national day of
mourning in recognition of course of
alleged atrocities carried out against
indigenous people by white settlers this
was the message that the left tried to
send again this past Thanksgiving many
taking the opportunity to post on social
media with messages like this this is
from journalist Walter Brahman who says
while giving thanks and celebrating the
holiday remember it is a national day of
mourning for Native Americans that marks
generations of broken promises and
oppression it is important to recognize
that Legacy as we grapple with a
resurgent fascist movement solidarity
forever and then he continues say it
with me the United States carried out a
genocide against this continent's
indigenous people and it served as a
blueprint for future Generations
a writer named Simon Moya Smith agreed
posting today is the national day of
mourning for indigenous peoples all
across uh this land we also call it on
Thanksgiving on this day we as natives
celebrate our resiliency and that we are
still here the U.S tried to kill every
indigenous man woman and child but we
are still here
and there were also acts of protests
around the country like in Chicago as
New York Post reports quote for the
second time in under two months a statue
dedicated to former President Abraham
Lincoln was defaced in Chicago on
Thanksgiving a statue of a young Abraham
Lincoln in sen Park in Chicago's
Edgewater neighborhood was found covered
in splotches of red paint along with the
words colonizer and land back
according to uh the Chicago Tribune the
statue also had Dakota 38 written on it
in reference to the Dakota Sioux members
who Link in order to be executed
following the Dakota war of 1862.
well it's a good thing that there aren't
any injustices happening in the world
today right now you know which frees us
up to frees us up to protest injustices
from 150 years ago that is quite a nice
luxury I must say
but you know there may be even something
to be thankful for I don't know just not
on Thanksgiving as the holiday is simply
too complicated now it's complicated
this indeed has become the media's
favorite term to describe Thanksgiving
with many outlets bringing in Native
American activists to talk about the
emotional complexities surrounding what
we all once thought was a simple and
wholesome holiday but it's not anymore
because it's just complicated watch
Thanksgiving of originally celebrated a
harvest Feast shared by Native Americans
and English colonists but as Fox 43's
Harry Lee explains the holiday can bring
out different emotions for indigenous
people
for many Americans Thanksgiving means
gathering with family to eat a large
meal together for Native Americans the
holiday isn't so simple a lot of people
in the Indigenous communities do want to
look at this the time of morning because
they see you know just what we have lost
after Europeans colonize North America
many Native communities were decimated
by disease famine and displacement Frank
Little Bear of the Plains Cree Nation
explains though that the many tribes and
families of indigenous communities now
celebrate Thanksgiving in different ways
he points out fall was always a season
of thanks axes started in October a time
of you know receiving the Harvest of
like the three sisters the corn Bean
squash deer things like that and really
preparing for winter so it was actually
a time of Celebration as for the
elementary school depictions of the
first Thanksgiving which often depict
Puritan English and Wampanoag tribe
members inaccurately dressed in Western
Plains attire I think yeah there's
there's certain things that they could
probably do better little bear says it's
still important to build a connection to
Native American culture from a young age
it's a building process that's not going
to happen overnight
build a connection to Native American
culture that's what thanksgiving's about
meanwhile the ACLU tried the repetition
technique posting on Thanksgiving
morning in all caps you are on native
land you are on native land you are on
native land you are on native land you
are on native land you are on native
land you are on native land you are on
native land
you are on native land Unfortunately
they only repeated the phrase ten times
if they could have if they could have
squeezed in that 11th time I may have
been convinced but they only got to 10.
now
uh there are a few points here that I
think are worth making first
of course the story about Thanksgiving
that we tell our children or used to
tell them is simplified
okay that's because young children are
only capable of understanding simple
Concepts you give them the simple
version first and then over time you
build on it adding layers of complexity
and in fact the left agrees with this
which is why they haven't actually set
out to give children a more complex or
nuanced understanding of the European
settlement of the new world instead
they've replaced one simplified story
with a different
but even more simplified story it's just
been simplified in the other direction
so the popular and simplified myth now
told not just the children but hammered
into everybody's head
is a story of evil barbaric white people
who came here and just immediately
carried out a genocide against peaceful
Indians who never did a single thing to
deserve or provoke any of the violence
visited upon them
this is the story we're supposed to
believe now
it is the new founding myth of America
you know every nation has its founding
myth right usually the myths are
designed to instill pride and patriotism
and gratitude
and yes they're not always 100 accurate
but people in other cultures and in
other countries they don't spend time
debunking well that's not exactly how it
happened they wouldn't have been dressed
like that
that's not the point of the story okay
to getting the Wardrobe details right
isn't the point
a lot of times the point is again to
instill Pride patriotism and gratitude
but our new founding myth is designed
instead to instill resentment and guilt
and shame
the modern Western world is the only
civilization in history that I'm aware
of
that lies to itself about its own
history and founding in order to make
itself seem worse
second as I've pointed out many times in
the past and we'll continue to point out
the claim that we stole land from Native
Americans from some group called quote
Native Americans or quote indigenous
people is incoherent there never was any
homogeneous group of natives occupying
this land before the settlers got here
okay it's not like the whole country was
was uh was uh occupied by this one group
that we would call Native Americans
there were rather disparate and warring
tribes that waged Wars of conquest and
extermination against each other and had
been doing so for centuries before we
arrived the ACLU says that we're on
native land but whose land exactly I
mean which natives
the ones who were most recently
occupying the land when white people
showed up or the ones who those natives
stole it from
or the natives who the natives it was
stolen from stolen from or the natives
who had it before that Etc
I mean you have to be more specific
but you can't be more specific because
there is no coherent chain of custody
for this allegedly stolen Land There was
for thousands of years rather only the
law of Conquest which is a law that all
people lived by and died by
that doesn't make it right doesn't make
it wrong it just makes it what it is
what it was it simply means that it
doesn't make any sense to try and
identify special victims of Conquest
because every conquered people were
conquerors before they were conquered
so
there are winners and losers in such a
system this is a distinction you want to
talk about they left once Nuance well
here it is
in a world governed by the law of
Conquest which is how the whole world
was governed for thousands of years
there are winners and losers
but it is much harder to identify
villains and victims
you know by the law of the land at the
time it's hard to make villains out of
Indian tribes that for example massacred
settlements
that's just how it worked and they were
on the settlements were on land that
those Indian tribes wanted or felt that
they had a right to
but it's also hard to make villains out
of the settlers who responded in kind to
that sort of aggression again it's the
way the world worked
we can only be grateful that we do not
live in times nearly as harsh or
unforgiving as that
and we can and should be grateful to our
ancestors who gave us
the comfortable and luxurious lives that
we lead
modern people love to Feast at the
banquet of Western Civilization while
still whining about the people who
provided the banquet
and judging them for doing what they had
to do in order to provide it
but you notice that none of these people
are leaving the banquet they're still
shoving their fat ungrateful faces
third and and this is the point that I
most wanted to drive home
and it is this
I am
a Native American okay I am a Native
American
and so are most of you in the audience
and I don't mean that in the Elizabeth
Warren sense I'm not claiming one one
thousandth Comanche blood or whatever
I'm saying that I was born here I am a
citizen and therefore I am a native I am
a native to this country and I am an
American therefore I am a Native
American
now that's a title that we really need
to start using correctly
any any legal citizen born in this
country is native to it and thus is a
Native American
we have no trouble recognizing this when
it comes to State citizenship now if I
told you that I was a native marylander
because I was born in Maryland nobody
would have any problem with that I am
native to Maryland because I was born
there
and yet somehow we have this idea that I
can be native to Maryland again
something no one would dispute
a native marylander and yet not native
to the country that Maryland is a part
of so I can say I'm a native marylander
but I cannot say I'm a Native American
because that title native to the country
is reserved for a very specific group of
people uh to a special victim group
because they were here originally we're
told
but they weren't
because if you trace it back far enough
every person who has ever lived on this
side of the world is originally from the
other side of it
nobody is native here in the absolute
sense
we are all descended from foreign Nomads
all of us
and yet my ancestors came here
just as the ancestors of those we call
indigenous came here
and my ancestors fought for this land
and conquered it
just as the so-called indigenous people
had done before them
and then I was born
and this is my country it is my home
it is my native land
and I'm proud of that
and I apologize to no one for it
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]